let's talk a little bit about what are
the negative effects of party controlled
primaries
uh so we've touched on it a little bit
and i've seen it um
so number one is you're gonna have an
incumbent from one of the two parties
um and so if you have a safe seat then
and i've been supporting candidates down
balance so i've seen some of this
um so you can have the person get
primaried from within their party
um and and then if they get to the
general then it's a foregone conclusion
like that you know you don't even need
to pay attention to the general really
in a lot of these districts in like 80
of the districts
so you wind up with only one real
challenge
to the incumbent and that is within
their party primary
because you have a party controlled
primary system
um so by the general election it's it's
already
determined who's going to win um there's
a quote by william tweed
uh that said um
[Music]
yeah that that said i don't care who
does the electing as long as i get to do
the nominating
and so um so so
the so the problem with the party
controlled primary system
is that uh it restricts voter choice
uh is that a fair way to characterize it
again i
i absolutely want more voter choice but
let's
fast forward i want more freedom for
legislators to do what needs doing
yeah you want a good result yeah again
the real problem
is not what they're saying in the
primary or who even makes it through the
primary
it's what they do once they're there we
if we
if we got rid of party controlled
primaries
some of the talented passionate elected
officials
will still win but they will now have
the freedom
to do what needs doing okay so so that's
one of the problems with the party
primaries but
here's the another thing that i think
you might you in particular might find
really
interesting i don't know if you'll call
this part in my book because it's short
i'm working a lot
longer article it's called the dual
currencies of politics
oh yeah i found this fascinating when
you talk about
votes and money um and that money is
actually a better currency because if
you get
extra you get to keep it uh and more of
it's always better
um whereas voting if you get extra votes
then you don't get to roll them over to
the next election
there's a lot of nuance to this so again
remember we're looking at now politics
as an
industry and so we're trying to find out
what's going on in this industry
and here's a lot of times i'm talking
about how it's similar to the for-profit
industry but now i want to talk about
how it's different
politics is the only industry i've come
across that really
has two currencies so think of it this
way
some customers in politics pay with
votes
voters some customers a much smaller
number
pay with money donors and special
interests who are also donors
and in large part
so we think a lot of times we have a
money in politics problem
and i want to say here we don't
what we have is a relative
value problem like we have an exchange
rate
problem like you know the dollar being
worth way more than
you know whatever the the euro is worth
or something point being
in politics right now the currency of
money
is worth unbelievably much more than the
currency of votes and i'll give you a
couple examples so as you said
first of all there's a limited utility
because
you only need one vote more than the
other person to win
the other and you can't carry them over
whereas money has no
upside limit on its utility but a couple
other things
the only time votes really have any
value
is in the party primary
but only in half of the primaries right
because
if if the district is gerrymandered or
even
naturally occurring a red district
the only votes that have any value are
the voters that turn out to vote in the
red republican primary so it's actually
if if voter turnout in a primary is 20
percent but you know 10
of the people are turning out here their
votes have
power and have value and then when you
get to the general election
each vote is sort of worth zero
because it's already decided determined
yeah
and you don't you also don't care if you
turn off lots of people with the
currency of votes
because again even if even if you made
everybody so
angry that only 10 people came out for
the election and there were 10 votes
as long as you got six and the other
person got four
it's no problem for you whereas you want
to keep turning out more and more people
sort of to be involved in money
but you're fine if you depress all the
people who are so disgusted with
with you know uh politics that they stay
home so one of the chain
so whenever we're looking at the
innovations i'm talking about i'm
looking at the behavior it's going to
incent but i'm also always looking back
at
how does it change the relative value of
votes to money
and i'm going to tell you a secret about
this money and politics problem
you know why there's so much money it's
just because
it's a really good investment the roi
is really good the roi on lobbying i saw
in a study it was it says something like
17 to one
i mean like where are you going to get
where the heck can you get a 1700
return on just about anything you do in
business i mean that's like
like if you're a rational business
person you're investing there you go
rational
rational behavior so here's the thing
what if we were able to
artificially decrease by a factor of 10
the amount of money in politics you know
so all the lobbyists are spending
uh you know one uh 10 of what they used
to spend
but we leave all the existing rules and
incentives for how people get elected
and the elections machinery and
legislative machinery intact
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
essentially make it 10 times
cheaper for the self-interested money
to get the same result
so here's the key make votes
more powerful than money
make that currency the one that matters
and then it won't make all money go
out but the point is if the votes are
more powerful you can't buy with money
what votes don't want
yes that's the dream therefore
therefore then the money that goes in
you know will
will lessen if it's not at all connected
with what's good for the country because
you won't be able to get the roi
on it you won't get the return yeah
people making decisions maybe i play
i can't get what i want exactly
and and that's and that's fair and and
rational
and so i am always telling people stop
going
after the money in politics and go and
making it less powerful and go
after making voters more powerful and go
after making
general election voters more powerful
having an open primary where everybody's
on the same ballot and then we'd have
five people advance to the general
election
and then you rank choice voting the
general which you know we can come back
to the package
that means that the election is never
decided in the primary
it's always decided in the general and
all of a sudden
every voter matters because using rank
choice voting
even if the district is deeply red or
deeply blue
that's so much less of a problem with
this system
we sort of leap frog over the need for
gerrymandering reform certainly not fair
gerrymandering and everything
but it's not the gating factor let's do
final five voting
open top five primaries plus
ranked choice voting in the general
elections and in the general elections
alone and you're going to you're going
to rank these five candidates
and then we'll elect someone with the
majority of
you know the broadest appeal to the most
number of voters but the main reason and
that's what a lot of
people that like rcv talk about is how
it's more fair and democratic and it is
those things and i'm for those
things but for the purpose of caring
about results
that make a difference in real people's
lives the main
and like the the biggest hugest benefit
of ranked choice voting
is that it's it eliminates the barrier
the biggest barrier in the politics
industry to the new competition
which is the spoiler argument
oh yeah don't vote for that person you
know you're gonna waste your vote etc
like you get rid of it
so right choice voting gets rid of the
spoiler effect it gets
it diminishes the incentives to campaign
negatively because if you trash someone
then
you both look bad and then the person in
third place ends up
uh coming up um it makes it so that
the ultimate winner has at least some
kind of level of
support among uh more than 50 of the
folks which right now if you end up with
you know split votes like you could have
some
person that no one really will not know
one but less than 50 percent of people
like
um ends up winning clearly winner like
happened with the governor in maine or
to some extent with donald trump during
the
primary process because there were there
were places he won with less than 50
um during the nominating process uh so
this is
both political parties a lot of times
the presidential primary
you know favors these plurality winners
and you don't get
sort of the person who's everybody's
second choice but nobody's
first choice yeah so this was an
appealing vision to me the top five
uh and plus ranked choice voting in part
because i was trying to imagine if you
were
an independent-minded person who was
considering running for office
and you got some people behind you and
let's say there's an incumbent uh let's
call
you know it could be either democrat or
republican it doesn't matter for this
example
but you think to yourself okay if i get
enough people behind me all i have to do
to make it to the general is be in the
top five uh
and that seems kind of achievable like i
just need to go out and get enough votes
to be in the top five and then if he
goes if i do get in the top five then we
all contend in a ranked choice voting
format
and then if i get a lot of people behind
me not even as their first race
necessarily but like i become everyone's
second choice because
um you know i i'm common sense and
suggesting things that people like and
you know like it seems like i'm going to
try to deliver
along with what most of us want uh so
that's like a very appealing vision uh
and so i i'm
i've always been a fan of right choice
voting and i think you and michael
helped open
my mind to the fact that the primary
system
is a huge component of who can
successfully run for office
and then what their incentives are after
they get there to your point
and now we know that the primary system
is a huge reason why votes have so much
less power than money
yeah that too uh because like you said
it's very constrained because
if you're not registered in that party
and one of like the the folks who shows
up to that primary then
you're just showing up to the ballot
being like well i don't even really have
and
this is one thing you really do have to
reflect on for a moment is that for the
average person in that district
they don't really have a meaningful
choice uh because if they weren't able
to participate
in the nominating party's primary
then they're just showing up to the
ballot box and being like okay i can
vote for one of these two people but one
of them is almost guaranteed to win
uh and it's one reason why people uh
write off politics because they're like
my vote doesn't matter like
like this is a waste of my time you know
when people have
that perspective um i look at them and i
think like this person may be rational
you know it's like there's some people
being like no you're a jerk for thinking
that it's like well
maybe they're on to something you know
it's like if you had a system where it
was truly irrational
then you could hold people to a higher
standard because you'd be like your vote
really does matter because you can
actually make a difference
you know and right now i tell people hey
look
if you only have time to vote once just
vote on primary day
like if you somehow can't do twice just
vote on primary day and
and and i also you know people are often
saying we need to have universal voting
we need to have mandatory voting we need
to
increase turnout and i say why are we
artificially trying to increase turnout
you know the best way to increase
turnout
make turning out matter thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]